foreign
[Music]
place for the big Fourth of July weekend
I can't leave my father this is the
first summer since we have to say
goodbye to you dear Mother and you'll
want to leave me to burn the spot
because alone why don't we just bring
him nah I don't think so here it is
ladies he's worried his immigrified is
going to make it look like some kind of
Goomba all right listen if we're gonna
do this Dad you gotta dial it down
what is this
wow this is amazing hey Mr fancy yeah
it's called love and affection man
unlike you when you met me at the
delivery room you chose to shake my
hands what else was I supposed to do we
just met
Sebastian I don't know how you're gonna
fit in my team don't these people have
jobs they got their money in the stock
market not mayonnaise jars buried in
their backyard
I just hope nothing gets stolen this
weekend because these people love to
blame the immigrants
this is
I love you these people are strange
they're birds for place he's like
ducks are just a bunch of goddamn
show-offs if you ask me
I was nervous to bring you here but I
didn't know you were going to spend the
whole time embarrassing me how could you
say that to your father Here We Go Again
everything I'm doing for you that I've
ever done for you is for your own good
hey man check it out I can die
I'm trying to make sure that you don't
make an ass out of yourself by trying to
be somebody you're not
oh my god oh [__] Sebastian your suit
it's Versace do you like it no you [__]
it's not up
honey my mom cannot see that
I would love to make a full Italian
dinner for everybody we don't keep a lot
of food here Amanda scalco always finds
a way to feed his family
my father has an old Italian saying
family isn't one important thing it's
everything I can't believe we put this
all together from what we have in the
kitchen it's artichoke and poultry
[Music]
oh no
oh
you slide up their pet peacock and you
thought I was crazy for worrying that
you were gonna make us look like some
bad Italian staff that's right to help
me get rid of the evidence why does it
seem like you've done this before
[Music]